hey guys Ryan right here Brandi fries
here we're gonna check out a video by
Rocco Rocco Rocco rack out and I'll say
Ronald McDonald chicken store massacre
I've got a request up the wazoo straight
up my [ __ ] into my belly button for
this request for this video man it's
Ronald McDonald chicken store massacre
that's I hope it's funny or I hope it's
like the game hatred Ronald McDonald
just burst in starts annihilating all
the kids in the playground oh yeah
start dark humor dark don't do it dark
comedy don't stop I have a daughter
Susie watch this so I want to listen I
want to play hatred I don't want to
listen to your darkness anymore
I don't know faded filiform laughs give
me the chicken now we just started to
steal back actually obviously budgeting
we got a whole bunch of impact we're
going to try to get someone in the
chicken cross the road to get the
clickity to you
[ __ ]
it is like a teacher
hi
Hey kill him
holy [ __ ] it's some real dark humor
right there oh my god it's one of those
things where it's like because it's
disturbing it makes it funny you know
they were all kind of cracking up at
some point
oh yeah especially that one actress was
like really laughing a lot yeah she was
like smiling every line she was saying
I've seen several other sketches now
what it's one of those things where I
know this like a common theme I see with
their skits it tends to be like you feel
that vibe of people like what if Ronald
McDonald just walked into a chicken
store started killing everybody and then
everyone starts laughing about it and
they didn't even they just make a skit
about it yeah it kinda reminds me like a
skit I would see on Family Guy where it
just gets randomly really violent it's
different when it translates into actual
human beings so that's why at times it
was just like flat like when he puts her
head in the fryer
yeah I was pretty like oh my god that's
kind of like I'm glad the makeup wasn't
like so [ __ ] up but yeah that might
have been funny I thought the fight
choreography was pretty good yeah it was
a good massacre mm-hmm it was a really
good massacre like I mean four is
especially something so low-budget
you know this could be like an actual
film in some ways you know like it
really a serial killer kind of clown
who's like kind of twisted and thinks
about McDonald lives on [ __ ] like a
Ronald McDonald has gone insane his
voice was so high yeah yeah when he
first shot that guy like first shot he
took that was so shocked yeah I was
we were both probably what i weirdly
admire that video a lot because it's so
[ __ ] up it's so dark but the concept
alone just is so silly that it makes it
all funny even though they're executing
it with a certain level of realism it
actually made it worked well anyway guys
thanks for telling me that was how that
dark the light if you're new to it is
yeah if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real
rejects you can checkout Brandis Channel
does a lot of reactions on there check
it out and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter
we're normally I would make a product
placement joke because with enough
followers we can get product placement
product placement all of us alright
let's do a shadow this person doesn't
have a name so here's what their name
looks like do you have it no that's not
a name it's not it's not a foreign
language name it's it's it's a it's a
picture of a caterpillar a giant
caterpillar trying to destroy a city
it's Arabic no it's not you're silly
this guy does not look Arabic if he's
from Arab then they don't have the gyms
in Arab he asked me a question said hi
how are you your are so amazing guy can
I ask you something but please don't be
mad and angry you gay and I told him I'm
not gay nothing wrong with asking and he
said thank you for the answer I wish I
can meet you now something tells me that
giant caterpillar taking down the city
is probably gay there's nothing wrong
with that I mean looking at your photos
I can see you workout in the gym
very sexy you're tatted up like I was
gay yeah I plug your butt but I'm not
gay